welcome back to grammar until today
stood by me Josh Smith and today we are
joined by the queen of girl power I'm so
good all the Seenu you know what is so
lovely isn't it that obviously we're all
quite far away from each other and
isolated but have this connection to
sexy faces have a chat have a catch-up
I guess she's due today doesn't it
that's like the only thing getting me
through hard that like a little bit
social connection you know because how
are you dealing with your own mind in
this situation this is such a difficult
situation you know there's so many
people going through some really
challenging times and you know I think
everyone's situation and has its own
challenges you know I have my family
here and it trying to get the children
to do work and to exercise and get
myself to exercise I'm having this
constant dialogue in my mind and I want
to try and get some benefits from from
this low down because even though it's
busy you have no choice but to slow down
and to sit with yourself and your
thoughts you've been on such a journey
the word journey doesn't even really I
think do justice how much stuff you've
been through how it's all had to happen
in the public eye and I mean you've been
famous for like decades that is just
such a nuts things have to comprehend
your career how is your relationship
with your own mind change and how has it
altered I'm definitely a lot kinder to
myself which I think everybody needs to
be more you know as a young person I
think I was searching I was searching
for who I was who I wanted to be then I
was being bombarded with few people
thought it was and who people expected
me to be and I just find that are not
really confusing I never felt good
enough I think like a lot of people I
experience a lot of guilt as well I felt
guilty about my success I
guilty about earning money I think
that's where I kind of got into hot
water because I was trying to make
myself worthy of all these things when
really you know we're all enough we are
actually enough my daughter always
laughs at me says you're a perfectionist
and I said well I'm not protectionist
because there's no such thing you know
I'm a failed complexin perfectionist
there's no such thing as perfect can you
remember a time when you were literally
trying to try and really be this perfect
image of yourself that you thought you
won't be but actually it wasn't even you
is there a time you call where that was
going through your head quite a lot
probably the early days in the band with
the girls you know no mid-90s and it was
you know there were lots of different
events that led to this but I think one
of the big things was being in the
public eye I'm reading about yourself in
the tabloid media because you're nothing
prepares you for that and when you're
reading about yourself and it's like
reading about a stranger in the 90s you
know before everybody had the internet
and social media it was very odd to read
about yourself and think who's that and
I think that's what you know wobbled me
quite a lot do you think as well having
this alter ego identity of sporty spice
which is literally just this insane
label that got put on you almost is that
almost been like a blessing in the class
in a way gosh how long has it been it's
been a long time my math isn't good but
you said 20 years and and I think
there's been times in my life I suppose
in the early days because I wasn't
natural who I was and I thought sporty
spice was something external to me and
when we did the stadium shows last year
and I had the opportunity to get back on
stage with the girls and perform our
songs again which was just incredible
and what was interesting for me was you
know for a few years I've been thinking
how can I run around on stage to want to
be and my omim authorities I'm a mum you
know it's ridiculous but once I found
myself in that situation it was like
second nature and it made me realize
that actually sporty spice isn't
something
you know I become it's in me hmm and
it's and it was really lovely and it
just made me feel really reflective and
just really be able to embrace every
part of myself even the [ __ ] I guess as
well because you have to always live up
to this sporty image right and then
you've been through a whole journey with
your body image as well did that
pressure you being the sporty one throw
your body image into a different filter
that you didn't even expect
I grew up dancing and doing gymnastics
and when I was a kid I was so active and
I never even thought about body image
and I went to performing arts college
and I was actually quite close to some
people with eating disorders and I know
a lot of dancers a lot of people in that
environment you know it is very
difficult obviously you look at yourself
in the mirror all day and you know I
mean I'm sure things are a little bit
different now and I know the modeling
world is the same but you tell to lose
weight you know there's a certain way
you're expected to look in that
profession and it never affected me but
that was select through my late teens
and it wasn't until the Spice Girls you
know really took off that I became
became very self-conscious about the way
that I looked and and then that's when
you know I was exercising obsessively
and I wasn't eating properly and I lost
a lot away and you know I was I was
living in an unsustainable and unhealthy
way for couple years how did you pull
yourself out of that gosh it took a long
time I was in denial for a long time you
know people did reach out within the
band in my family but I was I was
embarrassed and I didn't want to admit
it it was very obvious because I think
you know when people have an eating
disorder it's a very visual thing you
know it's obvious to look at somebody
it was obvious look at me that I was
underweight and people who were close to
me could see I wasn't eating me but I
didn't I wouldn't go there it really
turned
until my body made the decision for me
and I became very depressed around the
millennium and and I just couldn't cope
and so I ended up going to my GP and I
was diagnosed with depression and that
was really my first step to recovery
what do you think you learned about
yourself and that time well you know I
look back over that time and I you know
for many years I've been regretful about
everything and I'm sure there'll be
people watching this who have had
similar issues or maybe going through it
right now and it's it's so it's so
overwhelming you know anything disorder
it's like it's all you think about all
you think about is what you've eaten or
you know ways to avoid eating or
avoiding social situations and life is
from living you know I used to be so so
sad about so many years I've missed so
many opportunities to have a great time
and to really enjoy everything and what
I've learned from it is that I've been
there you know and and I've got better
I've recovered and I know the signs and
I don't I don't think I'm an authority
on it and I absolutely would know how to
deal with it but at least I can I can I
can have empathy you know with somebody
in that situation and hopefully my
experience can be helpful to other
people if you could take the you that
was going through that and they were sat
across they were on the screen right now
what would you want to say to that
person I would say don't be afraid and
this helped the one thing I do wish is
that I've got professional help earlier
and I think for you know people who have
friends who there might be concerned
about any mental health issues or people
in their family and I think it's really
hard it's hard to broach it it's hard to
know what to do what to say how to deal
with it and my advice would always be
get professional help you know and you
know one of the great things about the
internet is there are wonderful
resources out there you know you can
reach out you can get in
nation and yeah if I was talking to
myself I would say don't be afraid you
there is a much better life that you
deserve and you should be living so
let's work together and and make that
happen
hmm that's such a powerful statement yes
but I also just think that we've gotta
let ourselves have those moments when we
feel sad about the situation because I
think there's so much the time like you
strike me as a really positive person
and you kind of want to be the positive
person all the time right and then
you're like who live with me can hear
you now like she is a baby you
depression you know personally for me it
never really goes away I've never had
I've never found myself in such a dark
place as I did when I was first
diagnosed I think because I didn't
understand what was going on there was
other issues around it I hadn't I hadn't
had any help I didn't know how to deal
with it you know mental health is it's
an ongoing thing it's a work in progress
and so I have my ups and downs and I
think as a parent there's this kind of
there's two things there's one you don't
want your child to see you down and
upset but then on the other hand you
know it's good to think for children to
see that their parents can be verbal I
mean there's so much power in being
vulnerable and leaning into that
vulnerability as well like people don't
realize that and I think we spend this
whole time trying to be like we're
empowered people and it's like but
actually when you think about what it
means to be empowered it's to be tapped
into your emotions and how you deal with
them because I guess for you as well you
are such a symbol of that term Power
Girl Power and then I guess for you the
whole time you're like what what is the
downsides of always having to be
empowered I was in earnest I felt like
I'd failed everybody you know I I was
living this lie but but you're right I
think the thing about vulnerability is
we all have it all over the world all
these cultures all these countries you
know whatever your what your status is
if you're a celebrity you know the
amazing key work is that we're all
looking at so completely differently now
it's like we are all the same you know
we're all feeling the same feelings were
all going through the same experience I
guess when you came back to go back onto
stage you get masked yeah as the Spice
Girls
I mean lost my absolute mind babes -
times over we saw it but like for you
what do you think the lessons you've
learned from the first time out to that
time out what will those lessons and
what did you learn in between that time
the biggest lessons were to be more
relaxed about everything the girls make
fun of me because you know I do have
that perfectionist fails perfectionist
nature and you know the beauty of the
Spice Girls is we are a bit rough around
the edges we do go wrong and that used
to frustrate me because I wanted it to
be amazing you know and I'd really
relaxed and let go and with this show it
was it was more fun because I wasn't so
uptight do you think as well being in
isolation right now it makes you crave
that experience again was it making more
appreciative of what you've had a little
bit about really and the shows were so
incredible and we are constantly talking
and we would love to do more and at the
time it felt so magical and so special
it felt that we have to do more you know
it's like it's a crime not to so I I
hope and pray that were able to at some
point honestly us getting our [ __ ]
together it's ridiculous but well yeah I
keep putting this out into the universe
it's gonna happen do you feel like
you've had to modify your relationship
with success and that idea of success
and failure
how's that change for you
absolutely I think you know one of the
things about being part of something
which is an incredible success is that
there's always so much to live up to and
you can't you can't top the Spice Girls
do not master impossible and I think you
know it took a while to adjust to that
as a solo artist my first album
Melbourne star was really successful and
you know I had an incredible to plan
with that but like all careers you know
I've had my ups and downs and definitely
as I've got older and just yeah I think
this self-acceptance thing and just and
you know being a person who has suffered
with depression knowing that without
happiness nothing means anything you
know so that really is the most
important thing and you know I love what
I do and that's why I keep doing it
sometimes people say why do you know
obviously you don't need to work and I
do but also I bloody love it and I've
been lost without it and I'm so excited
about the new music it sounds and gray
and working with some incredible people
and there's some hungers on this record
yes yes well thanks you I pick I've
always put your out there good love you
up done Depok